let's kind of address the Ari Shaffir a
tweet because a lot of people are
talking about it and it's been a you
know a lot of people are kind of
reacting to it
let me read this very controversial
tweet Ari Shaffir Road Aretha Franklin
showed generations of black people that
big can be beautiful dooming them to a
diabetes epidemic roast in hell monster
um again it's a lot and I can understand
why that angered certain people Aretha
Franklin's an icon maybe one of the
greatest singers songwriters of all time
not songwriters but she's you know she's
a performer she's amazing she's an icon
and I totally understand why some people
were not appreciative of Ahri's
insinuation that somehow her being a big
woman somehow made diabetes prevalent in
the black community and that somehow
there she was somehow responsible for
that IIIi do understand why people are
angry about that and I think that re
does as well and you know he's faced
some consequences for that tweet well
you let why laughing mmm that's why what
is funny about that nothing cuz I don't
think it was that funny no was that very
offensive about Aretha Franklin mm-hmm
that's what people are angry with him
right yeah is that is that not it I mean
your [ __ ] is it is theirs I mean you're
looking at me like I'm wrong what well
you know about the the coke people were
mad at him about the Kobe thing what
what did he say about Kobe he said Kobe
died 28 years too late [ __ ] the Lakers
[ __ ] Kobe he's kind of celebrating that
Kobe died I don't know if you saw that
that's why people are upset yeah yeah
that's what it is
yeah the day dug up the Aretha Franklin
twins they're mad at him about yeah get
it up what he said about coke this is
[ __ ] crazy to me I had no idea
I thought they found in Aretha Franklin
tweet
let's see let me find this here Kobe
Bryant died 23 years too late today he
got away with rape because all the
Hollywood liberals who attack comedy
enjoy rooting for the Lakers more than
they dislike rape Big Ups to the hero
who forgot to gas up his chopper I hate
the Lakers what a great day hashtag
[ __ ] the Lakers that's why people are
angry yeah I get it now because I had
thought that they were angry because
they dug up the Aretha Franklin death
tweet mm-hmm well folks I'm kidding of
course that's our opening bid i I know
what happened I'm not out of it I'm well
aware of what's going on I you know I'm
like anyone else I you know I'm like any
other American I just you know survive
in a haze of junk food and self-hatred
and then every now and then I perk right
up when I hear that there's a
controversy and I get my ears and eyes
peeled and I you know feel things cuz
that's what we all need to feel things
now we need we need Rage to just feel
it's not enough to be like oh it's a
sunny day we need to feel like something
is being you know happening and
unfolding in front of us we love that we
like a controversy we like a fight we
like you know so I think that that his
tweet if when I look at it I go you know
I would not have said that I mean that's
but Ari is consistent with that bit that
he does where when somebody dies he says
some the most [ __ ] up thing he can say
about the person and he does it
rather immediately I think this is what
he does after every single notable
person dies or celebrity dies he goes
and he tweets something really hain
as their body is still warm and I think
this is clearly by far the most flak
he's ever gotten for it because this is
the biggest person he's ever said it
about you know Kobe's you know an icon
the whole entire city of Los Angeles is
mourning we have friends that have been
really upset because they've been like
Kobe was like a father to me which that
also doesn't make sense that's also Ari
saying the wrong thing but that's also
insane on the other side to say this
guy's your day dad if it when you have a
dad you can't that's not he's not your
dad she's what it is he said he's an
iconic figure and I and I get that
everyone's processing it in different
ways
but there's people I've seen on Twitter
they've been like he's look remember my
family what huh I'm lost but I do get
the importance of the the guy and you
know now I think you know people are
ease parents have been doxxed people are
calling in bomb threats to the venues
he's performing at I mean it is you know
I mean the intranet they they get it
poppin they really do I mean they don't
waste any time trying to dismantle your
life when something like that happens I
you know I remember when Dina Hashem
made a joke about xxx tents on the
wrapper and she had to make all of her
accounts private because you know like
black emo teenagers were threatening to
kill her or something I don't know who
that guy's fanbase was but I mean hey I
get it I've made a few jokes about Billy
Eilish and you know people they hurt you
know young goth women have you know
surrounded me you know the Roscoe's
chicken and waffles I've taken many many
beating for that you know I've taken a
I've taken some body blows for I've just
not a huge fan of the music that's all
ari is a funny guy he's been a good
person to me as as another comic he's
always been somebody who's looked out I
think for comics he's introduced me to
people he showed my stuff to people he
is not but I do understand why people
I'll never understand why somebody Doc's
at someone's parents I mean I'll never
understand why somebody goes online and
tries to like people that had nothing to
do with this like Ari's [ __ ] parents
survived the Holocaust like they had
nothing I think his dad survived the
holiday it's not only his dad's texting
him what to say about Kobe Bryant it's
oh it's so absurd that anybody would do
that that being said I I know why people
are angry and upset about it and um you
know hey I mean I think that we should
all choose our words carefully when
someone has died that is a beloved
figure you got to choose your words
carefully now you know I I have a video
where I say that Megan McCain will only
have sex with her father and I say that
she'll [ __ ] his corpse she'll [ __ ] his
corpse daddy and that's a video I have
right I say that Megan McCain will only
have sexual relations with her father's
corpse so and it's like you know fun
it's like a funny video to me I
understand maybe why somebody but if I
didn't do it the day he died but I'm
clearly not gonna get on like a moral
high horse about like what type of
things people can say I'm sure there's
things that I've said or will say that
might get people
you know what are you gonna do